Let me tell you something I learned
about Hitler,
which really I haven't recovered from my
shock from this,
so we've been looking at the
relationship between political belief in
personality.
Okay,
and your political belief is strongly
determined by your temperament.
So liberal left types are high in trait,
openness,
that's creativity and low in
conscientiousness,
but you can fragment conscientiousness
up into industriousness and orderliness
and the real predictor for conservatism
is an orderliness,
not industriousness,
and you might think,
well that's no surprise,
right wingers are more orderly,
hence Hitler's call for order,
let's say,
but it's one thing to to to posit that
and another thing to measure it.
Now it's measurable and it appears that
orderliness is associated with
sensitivity to discussed and this is
actually a really big deal.
It's a really big deal.
So there's a paper that was published in
Plos one about three years ago looking
at the relationship between the
prevalence of infectious diseases and
authoritarian political attitudes and
they did it country by country and then
within countries by state or province,
and the correlation between the
prevalence of infectious diseases and
authoritarian slash right wing political
beliefs.
At the local individual level was point
six,
and so I want to take this apart a
little bit.
Okay,
so the idea is that this is part of what
you might describe as the extended
behavioral immune system and one of the
problems with the interactions between
groups of human beings in our
evolutionary past was,
well exactly what happened to the native
Americans is you know,
they came out and shook hands with the
Spanish can keystone doors and then
within a couple of generations,
90 percent of them were dead of smallpox
and measles and mumps.
And so it's been a truism in our
evolutionary past that if you meet a
group of isolated,
if you're a group of isolated humans and
you meet another group of isolated
humans and you trade pathogens,
there's a real possibility that you and
everyone you know are going to be dead
in no time flat.
And so we have a disgust mechanism that
that produces this implicit,
let's call it racist,
racial and ethnic bias.
That is part and parcel of the human
cognitive landscape.
But the problem with that is that it's
rooted in a disgust mechanism that
actually serve as a protective function.
Now,
when I was sorting this out,
I was reading Hitler's table talk and
Hitler's table talk is a very
interesting book.
It's a book,
a book of his spontaneous mealtime
utterances from 1939 to 1942.
And I went through with this new
knowledge because people think of
conservatives as like or fascist as
afraid of those who are different.
They're not afraid,
they're disgusted and that's not the
same thing because you burn things,
you're disgusted by.
And so it was terrifying to me to read
it because then I also thought,
oh well disgust,
sensitivity is associated with
orderliness and you need order in a
society in order to maintain it.
And the Germans are very orderly and
that was actually a canonical part of
their civilization.
And part of actually what makes them
great and powerful and that just had to
tilt a little farther than necessary.
And all of a sudden everything needed to
be get cleaned.
And you know,
Hitler talked about cleanliness all the
time and he actually meant
that.
And so this thing that's emerging,
you know,
you talked about its biological basis,
it's evolutionary basis.
It is,
it's part of this deeply rooted disgust
system that protects us from dangerous
pathogens that can manifest itself in
and does manifest itself in the
political realm.
It's not good.
So I don't know exactly how to tease
this apart,
but I agree with your point about
there's an actual danger when
populations meet like a literal pathogen
danger and that that is liable to have
produced a certain instinctive fear of,
of the other,
which doesn't have to be limited to that
one thing,
but that's enough to generate a
selective force that would cause a
certain reluctance to meet.
But I want,
I want to point out that at least in the
West and probably universally human
beings when they go to war,
tend to dehumanize the other population
and you know,
so of course calling the other
population,
subhuman,
vermin,
whatever it is that,
that human beings do.
And my concern is that we are doing
exactly this with the Nazis are defacto
Nazis who were showing up,
uh,
on,
on our screens at this point that what
we are doing is we are comforting
ourselves by saying,
well,
that's a small outbreak of something
that makes these people subhuman,
justifies punching them or whatever.
And you know,
I'm not squeamish about there being a
right to violence when somebody is
threatening a way of life.
So it's not that.
But my concern is that if you take the
pathogen model and you imagine that all
those folks who showed up in
Charlottesville that that is a contagion
and it needs to be isolated,
then you will have the sense that as
long as you do that,
it's not going to show up somewhere
else.
Whereas,
which I think the,
the actual hazard is that that's
actually a latent program that has
served populations in past
circumstances.
It's indefensible,
but it has served populations and the
populations that we come from have it
therefore on reserve.
And when certain characteristics show up
in the environment,
that program can emerge.
And so my concern is that that's where
we are in history,
can't be isolated as a phenomena that's
associated with the other.